So look at the macro operators at a high level abstraction, consider this one
part of the current problem. Here is the initial state, here is the goal state,
there is the final plan. To enlist this idea of macro operators, and
hierarchical planning, at multiple [UNKNOWN] of abstraction, let us read with
this problem that we had encountered earlier. This was the initial state,
this was the goal state. And we come up, we came up with this as the final plan.
Now, we can think of these three operations as being abstracted out
into a macro operator that we can call unstack. And these three operations
being abstracted out into a macro operator that we can call stack-ascending.
Just simply saying stacking them in a particular ascending order. Here is
the specification of the two macro operators. Unstack, and stack-ascending.
You do preconditions and post conditions. And this macro operator,
also tells you how this macro operator can be expanded in to the lower level
move operations. Similarly for the stack ascending macro operator.